have you ever wondered what it would be
like to Simply tweet a single word and
quickly rack up 29 000 likes well if
you're the Hogwarts Legacy Twitter
account you don't have to wonder because
that's exactly what happened when they
tweeted out the word jump that's right j
u m p now when it comes to the whole
jump button situation in Hogwarts Legacy
I feel like there are two groups of
people out there the first group of you
is saying did he really just make a
video on a jump button oh wait people
have actually been asking about this
jump button why does it matter why is it
such a big deal and then the other half
of you is basically like
please give us a jump button we must
have a jump button no exceptions
the jump button has long been a staple
of video games and it's usually more of
a story when a game doesn't have a jump
button but with Hogwarts Legacy
carefully showing only footage of
characters exploring on foot or by air
or even in the middle of combat in fact
no player character has ever been seen
jumping in the game until now
in fact it's curious absence is what led
fans down the rabbit hole of speculation
wondering whether or not one would be
included at all and shockingly
surprisingly throughout all the Hogwarts
Legacy footage we had seen so far there
was never a clear example of a character
jumping which left many fans to wonder
and some fans like me to assume that
there actually was no jump button
perhaps they've taken a new approach
like say the new God of War which
replaced a traditional jump button with
a contextual jump button instead now if
you aren't familiar with this think back
to the old school Legend of Zelda games
such as Ocarina of Time Majora's Mask in
these games link did not have a jump
button like he does in breath of the
wild now if you ran across a ledge link
would automatically jump if you needed
to climb somewhere same thing very
similar to what the recent God of War
games have been doing which is in
contrast to the previous God of War
games on the PlayStation 2 and
Playstation 3 which had a dedicated jump
button and was really quite an important
part of kratos's Arsenal so does this
whole confirmation of a jump button even
matter and if it does what is exactly
does it mean for the gameplay well
that's what I'm gonna explain today and
I think we can look at a recent example
that will really help us to understand
this so let's take for example the
recently crowned Game of the Year Elden
ring now for a lot of long time from
software fans especially fans who have
played the souls games demon souls and
even bloodborne one of the biggest
pieces of information that came out in
the lead up to the game was the fact
that Eldon ring would be adding a
dedicated jump button now there are
plenty of videos online I'm sure that
talk about the significance of this for
the soul series some that really get
into the technical details of how this
matters in gameplay but I'm Gonna Keep
it pretty simple for you here and it
really all comes down to one word
exploration so let's take a look at how
the jump button changed up the formula
for the soul series and I think we'll
come away with a better understanding of
how it could play out in Hogwarts Legacy
one of the most obvious ways it
benefited Elden ring and will likely
benefit Hogwarts Legacy is by opening up
the overall sense of exploration and
freedom to explore by adding a jump
button the developers it from software
had more freedom to not only create a
wide-ranging open world but also one
with plenty of verticality in both its
landscape and the various physical
structures about the region you see at
its core the jump button and whether or
not one is present plays an incredible
role in the overall level design for a
game without one many of the more
vertical structures or obstacles
presented in games really end up
existing only as visual eye candy or
pleasing to look at scenery and they end
up not being a true obstacle the player
can overcome with some carefully timed
platforming now as someone who is
currently playing through God of War
Ragnarok and just replay through the
2018 version of God of War it's
interesting to see how these games with
no jump button at all handle that
exploration they have to find other ways
of getting around this God of War for
example has lots of climbing in fact the
recent one added a new mechanic where
you can use the blaze of chaos to kind
of leap to a certain point which is a
fun little design choice that actually
improves upon the first game because
you're not sitting there waiting for
Kratos to climb all the way up the
Mountainside now what's interesting
about this as much as I love these new
God of War Games there is a certain
linear feel to them now even though you
can go and fully explore basically
anywhere you go in god of war it always
feels like a linear exploration if that
makes sense and yet there's just
something about when you have that jump
button when you have that verticality
and that full scale map that you can
just look in any single Direction and go
there it is definitely what I would
prefer for Hogwarts Legacy and I'm
excited to see it going in this
direction now jumping back to Eldon ring
its open world is packed with detail and
plenty of Secrets for players to find
some of these secrets require very
precise jumps or leaping across a gap at
just the right time so even though we
have yet to play or see these types of
scenarios in Hogwarts Legacy but just
the fact that a dedicated jump button
exists actually tells us they're at
least possible now although primarily
used with close range melee weapons like
swords and axes Elden ring also used its
jump button to great effect in combat
jump attacks were added and were
actually one of the best ways in the
game to break enemy posture and open
them up for a visceral attack of course
Hogwarts legacies combat is expected to
be almost entirely ranged combat with
the various spells will have have at our
disposal but even if jumping isn't a key
part of our offensive combat Arsenal
it's almost certain to play a key role
in our evasive maneuvers along with the
Dodge roll mechanic that we've already
seen there may also be times where
securing a higher vantage point will
allow us to actually attack enemies from
afar or perhaps even Escape undetected
at the end of the day the jump button is
a design choice and an incredibly
important one at that now don't get me
wrong I have played and enjoyed many
games both with and without dedicated
jump buttons but the presence of one
here in Hogwarts Legacy actually leaves
me very encouraged about the
possibilities of exploration combat and
puzzle solving all things to the
presence of a dedicated jump button now
while gameplay is always going to be
king for me while we're out and about
exploring that open world we're really
going to need something nice to listen
to right The Wizarding World has such a
story tradition of delivering
spectacular music and it actually seems
like that is going to be the case with
Hogwarts Legacy as well we just got a
sneak peek at some of the music for the
game and I've already done a full
breakdown of that here you can check it
out on the right side of your screen now
as always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon
[Music]